c'est la nouvelle ligne de front ce
village désormais à portée de canon
russes maintenant que l'ici chance qui
est tombée une large fumée à l'instant
des bombardements
trois jours que c'est comme ça
quelques civils encore dans les rues qui
voit les russes arrivent et
je suis inquiet oui je rentre chez moi
et constamment
le sifflement des obus qui passe au
dessus de nos têtes
il faut s'éloigner un peu du front
roulait vers l'arrière pour trouver les
troupes qui bat en retraite ces soldats
et leur char abîmé inizmé de l'itie
challah oui
comment c'était
c'était un enfer
mais on l'a reprendra cette ville des
grappes de soldats sur un char
la majorité des troupes à quitter les
six chances que pendant la nuit
dans les bois cette section d'infanterie
les hommes dorment épuisé
nous saluons leur commandant
sur sa voiture des éclats d'obus qui ont
bien failli le tuer nous limiterons les
images des russes issenlor drapeau dans
l'ici chance
c'est quoi votre sentiment n'est qu'un
sentiment de dégoût et de
la tristesse tres bien sûr la colère bah
oui
ces fantassins veulent nous montrer les
armes avec lesquelles ils ont combattu
et donc perdu une mitrailleuse en fait
une antiquité
d'avoir elle date de 1944 c'est écrit là
et elle fonctionne bah oui bien sûr
à chaque tir ils doivent ajouter de
l'eau pour refroidir le canot et ils ont
aussi cette mitrailleuses légères modèle
soviétique des années 30
ça c'est pas comparable avec ce qu'ils
ont c'est rien pour se défendre
même le side car et d'époque
après la défaite la section attend
d'être à nouveau envoyé au front